this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream use the link in the description
to watch thousands of documentaries and
at no extra cost exclusive and add free
videos from your favorite creators on
nebula it's 5 o'clock you just finished
a shift in your small Wisconsin dairy
town you're on an evening stroll in New
York dinner is calling in a st. Louis
suburb then you step into the grocery
store and suddenly you're transported
somewhere entirely different here the
parking lots are never big enough the
lines always long and picking pita chips
somehow feels adventurous here you're
sophisticated you appreciate the
difference between met saloon a and
nonmetal oon a ravioli what is this
strange alternate universe and why is
everyone so scandalously friendly you've
just entered the 15,000 square foot
Californian embassy or more specifically
your neighborhood Trader Joe's like its
motherland the nation of California
Trader Joe's does everything a bit
differently it holds no sales offers no
coupons has no loyalty program no self
checkouts almost no advertising no
online ordering and collects no customer
data you'll either find its 25 cent
individually sold bananas quirky and
charming or endlessly obnoxious in case
you're unfamiliar Trader Joe's is a
popular American specialty grocery store
meaning you'll find things like the
veggie burger with almond butter tumeric
slaw produce and snacks but few everyday
essentials like batteries or toothpicks
for that reason the average shopper
makes routine visits but in addition to
their normal big-box grocery store its
devotees appreciate its cheap and wide
variety of wine and diet or food
restriction friendly choices like vegan
kosher and gluten-free foods it's
perhaps the only grocery store with a
cult following Facebook fan groups and
employees for life clearly it's doing
something very different the first thing
you can't help but notice as you enter a
Trader Joe's is its elaborate tropical
and nautical theme it doesn't feel like
an ordinary store because its aisles
aren't true
of rows of similar-looking items rather
it's more akin to a coherently designed
theme park ride unsurprising given its
inspiration before opening the chain its
founder Joe Colome had been on
Disneyland's jungle ride the titular Joe
and supermarket lore is a sailor on the
high seas
bringing exotic foods from faraway
places managers wear bright casual
Hawaiian shirts
sometimes with leis and are officially
designated captain's assistant managers
are first mates and regular employees
crew the walls aisles and floor are
decorated in wooden tiki patterns
between them you'll find Trader Joe's
second surprise and one of the key
ingredients to its success there are
almost no branded items around 80% of
its products carry the Trader Joe's
label with a unique package design and
creative often quirky names the average
shopper may see only one logo and one
consistent design from the entrance to
the exit in sharp contrast with the
average grocery store aisle where each
product independently fights for your
attention and yet in what might surprise
even the most frequent customers Trader
Joe's owns no factories it does not cook
build or create its recipes instead the
company approaches an existing brand or
vice versa and strikes a deal Trader
Joe's gets to put its name on high
quality well liked and pre-tested foods
the manufacturer meanwhile it's a new
source of income from a customer who
will buy regularly in large quantities
and pay on delivery rather than charging
slotting fees like most grocers both
agree to secrecy legally obligated one
another never to admit to the
arrangement there are however some
clever ways around this when the
American Food and Drug Administration
recalls a product its manufacturers
often release public lists of all the
stores and labels under which it's sold
the blog eater has used Freedom of
Information Act two requests to obtain
these lists and figure out many of
Trader Joe's suppliers while some of its
products are genuinely exclusive many
are very slight modification
different proportions or even exact
recreations of products available
elsewhere
meaning awkwardly you can compare prices
directly it's white cheddar macaroni for
example was discovered to be identical
to Annie's branded version but at Trader
Joe's 50% cheaper it's veggie steaks are
except for a few ingredients the same is
good health natural foods despite being
less than half the cost it also sells
products suspiciously similar to
Wonderful Pistachios Naked Juice
frito-lay chips and Stoppers animal
crackers this private label strategy as
it's known is not unique
Whole Foods has a similar brand called
365 and Costco has its Kirkland
Signature Trader Joe's though has
selected products and positioned them
well enough that shoppers see its brand
as Trader Joe's in other words customers
feel they're shopping at a premium
retailer like Whole Foods while getting
generic brand prices the best of both
worlds the downside of this strategy is
that products and relationships come and
go because each store sells only about
4,000 unique products compared to the
average grocery stores 40,000 it
meticulously manages inventory being a
customer means constantly being
disappointed as your favorite items are
discontinued or go out of season this
tight inventory management is also why
items sell out so frequently Trader
Joe's purchases directly from
manufacturers and its stores have small
back rooms meaning trucks deliver new
stock every day and predicting demand is
a difficult art to perfect the company
began private labeling back in 1972 five
years after opening the first store in
Pasadena California which is still open
today since then the company has
expanded to over 500 stores across 42
states plus DC with a strange omission
of Hawaii considering its tropical theme
despite this growth most would say it's
maintained that signature neighborhood
feel each of its 500 stores hires
artists to hand draw it signs and
reflect the local culture the brand
harkens back to a simpler time
one with less technology
one where staff were knowledgeable and
treated customers as friends it feels
nostalgic familiar somehow
even to those who've never lived in such
an era it's checkout stations have no
conveyor belts scales or TV screens and
instead of a PA system employees use a
literal Bell one deemed to call extra
cashiers two for general assistance and
three to notify the manager free samples
are handed out liberally and each store
makes its own merchandising decisions
catering to local tastes perhaps most
important though are its staff Trader
Joe's hires not based on skill but
personality it exclusively recruits
smart energetic conversationalist
extroverts here the customer is always
right some have reported successfully
returning dead plants or empty packaging
without a receipt the crew gladly helps
carry groceries to cars and are
expressly told to drop everything when
approached by a customer for any reason
they will always lead you to a product
not just tell you which aisle it's on in
fact to encourage these interactions
staff are told to stock products
throughout the day where they will be in
close contact with customers rather than
before or after the opening hours and
because these tasks are both physically
and socially draining workers frequently
rotate between them the job of greeting
customers at the door the helmsman and
Joe's parlance is assigned for no more
than one hour at a time and working the
register at most two hours together all
these quirks place Trader Joe's firmly
in an unofficial family of oddly similar
west coast at heart brands with
personality along with companies like
in-and-out and Costco all three have a
borderline cult following truly low
prices a reflective top-down management
style and treat employees not as
expendable objects but assets to be
nurtured
each appeals to the kind of customer who
has money but chooses to be frugal
someone who enjoys the comfort of a
small local establishment while at the
same time feeling a bit adventurous all
were founded by charismatic figures in
Southern California
and remain secretive about their
internal workings Trader Joe's
headquarters in Monrovia California is
tellingly nondescript
and the company rarely accepts requests
for interviews
although Trader Joe's founder Joe Colome
died in February
his legacy is undeniable he built the
place people look forward to shopping at
a place where everyone customers and
employees are treated with respect
some would say it's largely a facade
that its food may not be as healthy as
one would assume that the company is not
the pinnacle of environmentalism it
would have you believe and that a
national chain by definition can't be
local if one is being totally honest the
store has a slightly snobby feel to it
but whether or not you're a fan you
can't help but admire its ingenuity
building a brand that truly transcends a
mere name logo and mission statement for
better or worse Trader Joe's succeeds
because it exports California no matter
who you are or where you are here
everyone is friendly everything is
colorful and life is simple I don't
normally like talking about unreleased
videos but one that's been on my list
for some time is another secretive
well-liked company Lego I'm not sure if
this video will ever see the light of
day but in the meantime I really
recommend watching the secret world of
laïkó documentary on curiosity stream
it's full of interesting stories like
for example did you know there's a coast
in the UK where LEGO pieces occasionally
wash ashore because you're watching this
video I strongly suspect you'd enjoy the
technology science and nature
documentaries on curiosity stream and I
even bet you might even have a little
extra free time at the moment to help
get your mind off everything that's
going on right now you can get an entire
year's subscription for just $12 $12 and
this includes access to our new
streaming service nebula where you can
watch many ad free and even exclusive
videos from your favorite youtubers use
the link in the description to sign up
and you'll get an email with access to
nebula shortly after